A cause is a benign tumors, similar to the causes of cancerous tumors, toxic, overload, etc.
If you have a benign tumor, does that tell us something about our health that needs to change?
Well, yeah, whenever you have anything wrong like a benign tumor or a cancerous tumor,
or, you know, any type of side or symptom is a side or symptom that something may need to change.
I say it may need to change because it could have been something that you were exposed to years ago
that you don't have that exposure, you already changed that.
For instance, maybe you were living in a moldy house when you were a kid.
You picked up a lot of micotoxin, and that has caused damage and maybe even caused a tumor.
But if you did a micotoxin test today, your body had cleared it out.
That was maybe 20 years ago when you inadvertently cleared it out because your body is constantly trying to detoxify.
But it did lead lasting damage.
So it might not be something that you need the current change to.
But maybe you need the current change to help decrease the growth of that tumor.
So there's a lot of cancerous tumors like Lypomas.
Lypomas can have congenital ties to them, too, in their genetic predisposition to Lypomas.
A lot of non-cancerous tumors are very idiopathic, but they don't know what causes them.
The hypothesis is that it's the same as cancer.
It can be toxin, et cetera, that can lead to that, but there can be genetic pieces to that, too.
But yeah, like anything, you do want to investigate current exposure to different things.
You do want to investigate toxic levels.
And you do want to support detoxification pathways, et cetera, especially depending on where the benign tumor is.
If you have a benign tumor in your head, that's a space occupied lesion where you have only so much space.
So that can cause just as much problem as a malignant tumor in the brain, too.